de las cuatro Víctimas de secuestro de
los ciudadanos estadounidenses en México
dos de ellas están muertas una persona
está herida y la otra está viva sí lo
dijo directamente al gobernador de
Tamaulipas Américo Villarreal hablando
por teléfono en conferencia de prensa
diaria con el presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador los cuatro
estadounidenses ingresaron inicialmente
a la ciudad fronteriza de Matamoros en
México desde brunchville Texas en una
Minivan blanca con placas de Carolina
del Norte Cuando hombres armados
empezaron a disparar contra su vehículo
así lo dijo el FBI luego los hombres
armados subieron a los estadounidenses a
otro vehículo y se los llevaron las
autoridades mexicanas consideran varias
teorías sobre el ataque entre ellas de
que los estadounidenses fueran
confundidos con traficantes de
inmigrantes haitianos sin embargo
estadounidenses viajaron desde Carolina
del Sur a México para acompañar a un
amigo hacerse la abdominoplastia ya que
la cirugías estéticas son mucho más
económicas en México
Vocero de el Consejo de Seguridad
Nacional de Estados Unidos dijo a
periodistas desde la casa blanca que
Estados Unidos estaba trabajando ya con
las autoridades mexicanas para obtener
mucha más información sobre este
secuestro en Matamoros y que las cuatro
víctimas regresarán a Estados Unidos muy
pronto